[Music]
we have received when candidacy from
member states which was put forward by
Ireland the Eurogroup unanimously agreed
to endorse Philip Lane governor of the
Central Bank of Ireland for this
position
we also discussed today to post program
surveillance of to member states Ireland
and Portugal
in both countries the crisis is a
distant memory we also had a discussion
based on the latest economic forecasts
presented by the Commission there is a
mixed picture on average there is a
slowdown in the pace of growth but the
economic fundamentals are still solid
and the euro area is growing creating
jobs and increasing investment
description constructive shouldn't be
jealous or no hope no budget Arizona
hope they could get some carrots that no
shame collaborative
polyphenol small service this morning
from charelle I started by informing the
group this afternoon about the latest
post program submissions to Ireland and
Portugal in both cases repayment
capacity remains sound Island which
obviously has had a very good economic
performance at last few years was the
highest growth rates in the euro area
for several years has some risks on the
external side you're all aware of praxis
with respect to Portugal I share the
view expressed already that developments
on the economic and budgetary side have
been very good in recent years improving
convergence and competitiveness which is
the the aim of this budgetary
instruments that we discussed what
obviously also improve the resilience of
monetary union